merci georges donc mon intervention
porte sur les campements illicites et
quand on parle de cela évidemment on
pense aux gens du voyage alors ils ont
fait l'actualité
fin septembre à roy lors que lorsqu'ils
ont bloqué une autoroute occasionnant
par là près d'un demi million de 2,2 du
coût pour la collectivité
on pense éventuellement à moirans ou là
on a vu des scènes absolument incroyable
de guérilla urbaine
mais il y a aussi tous les manquements
tous les campements illicites qui un peu
partout s'installe en france sur le
territoire de nos communes moi je suis
mère et comme de nombreux maires je vis
chaque été un enfer avec les campements
illicites des gens du voyage qui sont en
itinérance et là je dois vous dire que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
difficile d'abord parce que et même
lorsque l'on remplit les conditions
légales c'est mon cas dans ma ville j'ai
une aire d'accueil des gens du voyage
bien entretenu chaque année dégradée
qu'il faut fermer chaque année pour la
remettre en état et qui sera à nouveau
dégradée l'été suivant
j'ai une un espace dédié à l'accueil
familial pour les gens du voyage
sédentarisés donc on ne peut pas me
reprocher comme à tant d'autres maires
de ne pas remplir nos obligations
légales
et pourtant malgré cela nous avons des
occupations illicites sur les zones
d'activités économiques sur les terrains
de sport sur les parkings enfin bref
partout où l'on peut s'installer
nous voyons cela et cela crée un climat
extrêmement difficile
alors je voulais vous dire que lorsque
comme moi et comme tant d'autres maires
nous décidons de combattre ces
campements illicites c'est véritablement
un parcours du combattant
parce que les procédures sont
compliquées
ce que les pouvoirs publics doivent
intervenir un peu partout dans leur
département et que c'est très difficile
et donc il faut avoir la foi chevillée
au corps pour faire respecter la loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
yannick moreau nous avons décidé de
déposer une proposition de loi et 7 ce
texte a été présenté il y a quelques
semaines et le gouvernement par une
motion de rejet a refusé que nous
discutions notre texte alors là je
voudrais dire très clairement que les
socialistes sont pris en flagrant délit
de mensonge à moirans le premier
ministre veut rétablir l'ordre
républicain
mais à paris on nous dit qu'il faut
lutter contre les discriminations dont
sont victimes les gens du voyage à
moirans on soutient le maire on lui dit
qu'on comprend les difficultés qu'il
vient de vivre
mais à paris on fustige les maires ceux
qui n'ont pas encore rempli leurs
obligations en matière d'aires d'accueil
de gens du voyage ou des aires de grand
passage en leur disant au fond puisque
vous ne respectez pas la loi
ne vous plaignez pas que d'autres ne la
respecte pas non plus donc vous voyez
nous sommes véritablement dans une
tartufferie un double discours qui est
insupportable
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faudra que nous revenions sur ces sujets
parce que à force d'impunité et bien
nous vivons moyrand nous vivons roi et
nous vivrons encore d'autres épisodes de
cette nature parce que véritablement il
y a un sentiment d'impunité
nous proposons quelques mesures simples
et qui sont tirées de l'expérience que
nous vivons dans notre quotidien de mère
tout d'abord nous voulons élargir le
champ d'application de l'évacuation des
campements illicites à l'ensemble de la
collectivité qui a compétence en matière
de gens du voyage pour éviter que les
campements illicites ne se déplace de
quelques mètres et nous obligent à
recommencer une procédure qui permet au
final de garder les gens sur son
territoire pendant des semaines
ça c'est simple mais
ça serait extrêmement utile pour les
mères deuxièmement nous voulons insérer
une référence directe dans la prise en
compte du trouble causé aux intrusions
illégales sur les terrains économiques
parce que l'ia il y à des enjeux
économiques
lorsque des gens du voyage s'installent
sur une zone d'accueil ou sur une zone
commerciale
et bien tout simplement tout bêtement ça
fait fuir les gens et ça compromet
l'activité économique de ces lieux nous
voulons réduire les délais de procédure
pour pouvoir être beaucoup plus réactif
et dispersé les campements illicites
enfin nous voulons renforcer les
sanctions pénales
et sur ce point je voudrais vous livrer
l'analyse qui est faite par le
gouvernement
lorsque nous donne demandons à la
ministre qui est en charge de ce dossier
c'est elle qui était au banc lorsque
nous avons voulu examiner notre texte de
loi sylvia pinel sylvia pinel nous a dit
pourquoi voulez-vous renforcer l'arsenal
pénal puisque les les peines ne sont pas
prononcés et ne sont pas exécutées
autrement dit ça ne sert à rien
d'appliquer des sanctions puisque toutes
façons de renforcer les sanctions
puisque elles ne sont pas appliquées
dont bella la perversité tout de même du
raisonnement et c'est une ministre qui
dit cela en effet mon cher patrick voilà
donc nous ce que nous voulons
chers amis qui était spécialiste de ces
questions
c'est véritablement donnée aux maires
qui sont parfois dans un état
d'accablement et de découragement total
les moyens de pouvoir tout simplement
faire respecter la loi et je dirais
faire aussi en sorte que ceux des gens
du voyage qui se comporte bien car il y
en a ne soient pas pénalisés parce
qu'ils se comportent véritablement comme
des sauvages je vous remercie
c'est beaucoup